Probably a good idea,
but then you look at Whitaker,
who's 85 such you,
he's stocky.
He's not like huge.
He's like the perfect size Whitaker cause he's still can knock out anybody,
but he's got awesome cardio and he's strong.
He's not as strong as Yoel Romero,
but he's strong enough to hold them off.
No one is who is one is you got to get that,
that Cuban gene pool to get that because you know what I'm saying?
Like there's,
there's certain gene pools like that fucking mountain from game of Thrones.
There's some gene pools out there,
man.
But yeah,
and then we throw in steroids in that pool.
Oh you do?
Do you say admitted to it?
Of course he did.
Yeah.
He was like,
yeah,
no shit.
Yeah.
And then when they kept asking him about the guy you currently taken,
he goes,
listen,
I don't want really want to talk about this.
It's like,
yeah,
no,
of course I am.
Why are they asking questions like that?
And that's the strongest man contest.
But think about,
come on dude,
who's going to win you?
Who gives a fuck.
How about a style bender?
Verse Whitaker?
Yeah,
the all oceanic fight.
Are you really going to fly to Australia for that powder?
Are you thinking about it?
Dude?
There ain't.
There ain't two dudes on this planet and get me to fly to Australia too.
There's not it.
No dudes on this plan to be there live though.
Nels.
Yo,
I'd rather be here.
Tom,
you're crazy.
I love Australia.
But now for Brianna was like,
Yo Dude,
get,
does stray light like I'm on my way.
Say No more fam.
No,
not two dudes.
Yeah,
but that fight,
dude.
I want to see that fight in the flesh.
Live.
You're going to do it.
I think I might.
I want to see that.
That goes down.
I want to see fight would occur is a fucking animal man.
Just thinking about how much pain that guy had to be in to an almost fight with
a hernia and a ruptured.
He had a ruptured rectum,
right?
Was it ruptured rectum,
I thought was just a hernia.
That was fine.
No,
no.
I think he had two major injuries.
No,
I know his intestines were popping through.
Yeah,
but I think it was another one.
Damn.
His rectum was fucked up too.
Isn't that,
didn't have a tear because I called a Jamie and find the hemorrhoid.
No,
no,
no.
Like a tear in his ass.
You don't think about the lighthouse drain from sparring?
Just think about getting taken down while you're trying to throw a kick.
You land fucked up on your hip.
Never ripped my asshole.
You can rip your ass hole.
I'm just saying I had drastic,
you catch a kick in the ass hole easily for sure.
Sure.
People whose eyes,
how about someone misses spinning back,
kick low and it just catches your tank.
Oh Man.
Just the heel hits your taint,
rips your tank away from the bone.
That shit happens.
I wonder what I,
I don't even know what the odds would be.
I would assume Whitaker's a slight favorite in that fight.
I would say so.
Yeah.
I would say,
you know,
based off one Helvin did well based off with Calvin did based off Whitaker's uh,
two fights with EOL.
He's been the only guy to hold yo off.
Although it does have said that.
I did think that you all won the second fight.
Interesting.
I thought Yo.
I think by go either scoring Yo wow.
Had them rocked and hurt by the new scoring.
I felt like it should have been worth more.
You does.
She had been at ten eight.
Yeah.
I mean he had him almost out hurt.
He hit him.
He staggered.
We didn't see him do that to Yo UL,
but buddy did survive around and survived.
He survived.
He won more rounds.
It's like how much all of the draw,
if you're watching a fight,
if a fight is a fight,
if it was,
I mean I understand it's a sport,
but it's the sport of fighting.
If you're watching a fight and one guy is really fucking a guy up and the other
guy never does that,
who do you think won that fight?
Do you think that you're right,
you can't.
Yeah,
but do you think the guy that just moves around and touches him with the Jab,
and I'm not saying this with Whitaker did,
but just as as a what if,
if a guy's just moving around for four rounds and he's touching you with a jab
and lay kicking you and shut and you were like fighting in the street,
but then in the fifth round you knock him down four times.
You beat the fuck out of him and he's running away from you.
His nose gets bloodied,
you end the fight with your hand raised without a mark on your face and the
other guy's face is pizza.
Maybe I'd look at my boys by Dan for that first 20 that boy is moving.
Right,
right,
right.
It's quick.
It's a good question.
It's cause like what?
How much is that round work has a sport though.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
Because as a sport,
yeah,
it's tough to judge it.
If you're going to judge it on a scorecard,
you have to be,
it has to be punitive.
The question is like how much is it worth for a guy to really take it to a guy
and almost stop him?
See I don't,
I think there should be more draws.
I don't have a problem with the draw.
I don't have a problem with drugs when that fight,
if there was drama like that makes sense.
Redo it.
Let's get a clear cut winner.
I think when a person gets really rocked like that,
it's worth more than a point.
I think it's worth more than two points.
I think it's worth a lot.
You think she'd be like ten seven think it's a big deal.
Got then you fuck you.
Fuck you are fucking real life here cause or rough.
Well no cause real life you're kind of fucked,
right?
Like to the idea that you could go through around,
you don't know who won right around where.
It's like a lot of feeling out,
a lot of touching,
you know,
this and that and you know,
okay,
perfect example.
First round.
Anderson Silva versus style vendor.
Okay.
You could give it to style bender for sure,
but it was,
it was a round where they were feeling each other out.
There was not one big moment where,
Oh my God,
style benders,
take it over.
This fight is almost done.
So that's ten nine but yet another fight where a guy beats the shit out of a guy
and doesn't drop him and they have exchanges,
but the guy gets rocked and hurt.
That is that ten nine two I know it's weird.
What if he had takes them a drop?
Some of the guy barely survives.
You Hammer fist them attended the bell.
Is it ten nine in the old system?
It is,
but what is it in the new system?
Is it ten eight but if it's,
even if it's ten eight I think it should be more than ten eight like that guy
ran out,
but the only thing is your fuck.
Let's say you do at ten six or seven right.
Then get dropped.
It's going to be tough.
You got to get him in his argument against what I'm saying.
Here's the argument against it.
Frankie Edgar versus gray Maynard.
Especially the first one,
right?
Gray Maynard drops him as him,
badly hurt in the first round.
Frankie manages to survive and come back and win enough rounds.
And when the fight exception though,
but it is exceptional.
It's kind of,
if you gave him like five points for that round.
Yeah.